[Musik]
es war hat mir ist das öfter so dass sie
hierbei war noch nie bei mir bei der
warmen fahrrad und auch erst mal eine
tüte genau das habe ich auch gedacht das
ist neu als gedacht von herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen essens video
mal wieder das haben wir jetzt irgendwie
länger nicht gemacht aber es hat sich
auch nicht angeboten sag ich mal
ich möchte nämlich heute wieder ein
neues restaurant testen von lieferando
was ist glaube ich jetzt seit ein paar
stunden oder paar tagen habe es gerade
gefunden damit 0 bewertungen also da hat
noch niemand vorher eingekauft das heißt
wir sind wieder die ersten bestellen und
die ersten jahren auch nur bewertungen
schreiben können und wir wollen
natürlich hier niemanden ruf schädigen
oder so deswegen hoffe ich dass die
bewertung auch positiver ausfällt so
bevor wir starten würde ich sagen ganz
kurz noch vorgestern kam der shop online
der alex wii shop da wird zum beispiel
diesen sugar beat das a steht übrigens
für meine anfangsbuchstaben oder
untersucht habe ich gerade
wahrscheinlich schon alles eingebettet
also wenn er da bock drauf habt dazu
bestellen
hier kommen die produkte noch vor
weihnachten an wenn man jetzt bestellt
wird es glaube ich schon gestellt und es
gibt handsignierte autogrammkarte bei
monte genau die haben
ich hatte auch noch reiche araber jetzt
auch direkt zum thema und zwar habe ich
ein restaurant gefunden
ich glaube dass irgendwie cooler wenn du
so direkt vom bildschirm abfilmen kannst
anstatt dass ich jetzt wieder eine
bildschirmaufnahme mache das nennt sich
büros restaurant hermes und da gibt es
wahrscheinlich büros und ich muss sagen
wenn ich hier so oben ein banner sehe
das sieht schon schön aus alternative
krankenwagen ist das heute hat christian
geworden 4 und 2
wir dachten sie auch was geht wenn man
hier umschaut salate pizza pasta
schnitzel snack berger indes klassiker
saucen also eigentlich haben die neben
büros das haben was passiert oder bahn
fahren hier immer was los hier
dann wurde mir hat irgendwie drei leute
festgenommen bei uns im haus
nein gut wir wollen eigentlich nur was
bestellen also dann würde ich sagen ich
schaue da kurz mal drüber suchen ein
paar sachen aus zeigt ihr euch denn und
die bestellt hast du auf dem was lust
juli guck mal hier gibt es auch wieder
pizza eine pizza gibt es ja irgendwie
überall ich hab halt schon mal büros
bestellt so eine kita und die wahrheit
vollversicherte ja also an sich müssten
wir das jahren mal bestellen ihren
wiener schnitzel mit pommes viele
schnitzen ja weil das ding heißt ja auch
schnitzel oder ist ein grieche harris
oder paketzusteller hermes möchte
expandieren hat sich ein neues
geschäftsmodell überlegt macht jetzt
auch für ob also gehört es schon sagen
dass ich was bestellen sein okay haben
deshalb gut zu bewerten weil so
hamburger kennt sie ja bei mir aus mit
pommes frites gyros mit zaziki ja dass
das nehme ich jetzt schon los mit pommes
dazu nehmen wir dann nachher getränke
brauchen wir eigentlich nicht das ja
unnötig ich will trotzdem hier noch so
ein paar andere sachen bestellen der
können wir bestimmen wir das schnitt
sind das mittel auch noch zu vertreten
ja margarita ist irgendwie so ein
bisschen laugen ob ich mal das kriegt ja
eigentlich jeder halbwegs pizza montreal
mit schinken salami und zwiebeln kann
ich an zu schreiben ohne zwiebeln und
mal gucken ob es ohne zwiebeln passiert
ob beste kommt mir das doch ganz gut ich
schreib bitte ohne zwiebeln amk
ok so wir haben jetzt hier 15 euro 70
das gyros müsste ja eigentlich nice sein
weil bisher einen cross restaurant und
wenn die kürzlich gut ist dann ist das
eben so kann man verstehen aber wenn das
geschlecht ist und die plätze gut
oder halt beides schlecht es das wär
halt nicht so gut
und im letzten video habe ich irgendwie
sehr oft gelesen dass ich so pingelig
bin oder so weil ich halt gesagt habe
dass es mir nicht geschmeckt hat warum
soll denn sonst diese videos machen wenn
es sich wenn es mir nicht schmeckt sei
es halt auch und es kostet ja auch viel
du machst du immer mit lisa mit den
integrierten web archiv
nicht mehr sonst würde ich auch mit
paypal machen ok ihre antrag wird
bearbeitet
ich hasse es immer wenn solche sachen
dann nicht funktioniert eine bestellung
ist eingegangen lieferzeit 30 minuten
also ich würde sagen da kann man nicht
mehr krank werden jetzt auch das habe
ich eine mail bekommen vielen dank für
deine bestellung
was haben wir gerade 16 oder so nennen
37 minuten und ich habe schon hunger auf
meinen schnitzen habe ja gar nicht
bestellt ich denke ganz ein schnitzel
auf meinen will raus mit pommes frites
und vielleicht auch okay heute herzlich
willkommen zurück essen ist angekommen
ich hab's ja nicht drauf weil ich war
gerade am pc hat er geklingelt es war
hatten wir ist das öfter so dass sie
hier noch nie bei mir und bei der warmen
fahrrad und auch erst mal eine tüte
genau das habe ich mich auch gedacht das
ist neu aber muss man ja sagen muss dass
ich habe gerade schon anguckt das ist ja
auch so dieser standard pizzakarton es
gibt doch keinen anderen oder jetzt
bestimmt auch auf busse oder so und
jetzt hast du auch was ich glaube schon
machte so echt kein was hat sie gekostet
97 also und war das nicht mit schinken
und salami und zwiebeln aber ich habe ja
ohne zwiebeln geschrieben ja aber guckt
da zu finden drauf da so linken brauchen
keine zwiebeln das stimmt schon der
songs darunter ok ja gut wenn du mir
sagst ja ja stimmen herzlich kurzum das
nämlich zurück okay dann haben wir das
schon und das muss man auch mal sagen
das fehlt bei vielen ihrer services so
servierte naja das ist verwirrend als
auch ein schädling aber so
plastikbesteck will ich gar nicht aber
servierten als ich müsste jetzt
praktisch so eine art führer stella drin
sein
[Applaus]
ich glaube das kannst du nur um hatten
anhand des geschmacks bewährten wirklich
glaubt auch aber was ich sagen muss ja
jetzt werden wahrscheinlich wieder
kommentare kommen aber ich finde dass
wir aus fleisch also wir waren auch
damals selber malen griechen gyros essen
und normalerweise müsste dass wir so ein
bisschen dünner sein weiße und dicker
das ist halt echt digg com
das ist finde ich schon viel zugkraft
ich bin halt anders geworden sagen wir
mal so aber trotzdem kann er gut
schmecken so haben wir jetzt die pommes
ich bin echt um das ist ziemlich war
gestern noch kommt bin ich dachte
eigentlich dass wären dabei also die
panischen einstands gut 1 bis 10 07
also zu wissen sind die sind auf jeden
fall krank gehörst was ich aber gar
nicht mal so schlecht
und ein bisschen laibach ich aber das
liegt aber es wegen der vermutlich auch
in der liefer dauer ja manche sehen das
auch als qualitätsmerkmal wenn das so
dicke scheiben sind also das gut ist ja
weil manchmal kriegt halt echt nur so
richtige ranzige scheiße in dein peter
rein geschaufelt wenn sie jetzt noch gut
schmeckt finde ich das gar nicht mal
schlecht es halt geschmackssache
meinst du was ich noch sagen wollte die
sitzen weil sich im restaurant und
wundert sich darüber ist eine bestellung
eingegangen weil der immer noch keine
bewertung ja das heißt ja nicht dass sie
nicht ausgeliefert haben ich hätte
vielleicht hat einfach noch keiner würde
ja klar aber es ist ja schon gut wenn du
irgendwie so 20 bewertungen hast weil
würdest du jetzt dabei stellen
wahrscheinlich nicht konnte
ich traue mich schon gar nicht mehr
meint er nicht nur zu sagen also mit den
comics geht es ist gut angekommen es ist
brutal trocken natürliches 40 ja auch
aber das fleisch ist es trocken so ich
bin halt einfach komma werten neben
unserer schule damals hatten wir mal so
ihm da war ich sehr oft in der
mittagspause mit dass reisebüros und
dazwischen liegen welten irgendwie warum
auch immer ich weiß nicht 1 bis 10 vom
fleische also die promis gehen auf jeden
fall voll klar dass fleisch natürlich
werde ich jetzt hier gehörte wird das
ganze vielleicht mal so ein bisschen
aufgewärmt werden aber ich hätte ja
trotzdem mal nur das fleisch problems
meiste und also fleisch 15 komme es
sogar acht und zehn okay also ich sag
mal so dieser gehörst alex ist in
ordnung er würde mich jetzt nicht dazu
bringen dass ich eine schlechte
bewertung schreiber so also man kann auf
jeden fall das bestellen und ist auch
essen das schmeckt okay von jetzt haben
wir hier noch kürzer was hast du s pizza
experte soviel sich gerade hoch gehoben
hat sie gerade hoch gerufen wird könnte
halb von der größe eine perfekte
tiefkühlpizza sein glaubt nicht dass mit
philipp alleine auf keinen fall das
sieht man am rand aber bei der bin ich
mir unsicher schmecken würde ist halt
sehr klein für sieben euro
ja die nämlichen steckt ja aber ich sehe
doch darunter hits stimmen welche die
pizza kompletter durchschnitt haben eine
schlechte presse eine pizza kannst du
mal richtig abnormal scheiße das ist
eine typische liefert aber nicht nur
fünf für mich ich würde bewerten so viel
von 10
ok also ich es halt mal salami schinken
deswegen leute im ältesten passenden
abschluss zu finden also ich muss sagen
mir gefällt die pizza das heißt das gros
des jahres bin ich halt feiere ich jetzt
echt nicht so ich kann das auch
verstehen wenn sich dann einige
aufbringen und sagen hey james mit
seiner cd bestellen müssen ich weiß dann
hätte das ganze vielleicht noch ein
bisschen besser gemacht aber trotzdem
es hat mich halt einfach nicht umgehauen
meiner meinung nach muss gestehen klein
geschnitten sein kann ich vielleicht
auch noch kurz sagen ich hatte hier in
köln
in einem kleinen auto und da bin ich
nämlich aus wie sie niemandem leicht
drauf gefahren war beim mega cool weiß
auch nichts im auto und so und der ist
besitzer von seinem büro aus grill oder
mehreren floors grillen hier in köln und
umgebung und der hat mich dann zur
eröffnung eingeladen und das gehör was
ist wirklich brutal egger und das habe
ich jetzt halt weiter wochen da auch mal
gegessen deswegen das ist halt einfach
da ist einfach so ein großer unterschied
zwischen deswegen man könnte auf jeden
fall bestellen und das essen aber es hat
mich jetzt nicht vom stuhl gebrauchen
praktisch nicht vom stuhl geworfen
klassen nach oben da aber nicht den
kanal bald ein region und wir sehen uns
dann morgen zu einem neuen video und
wenn ihr bock hofft dass ich weiter
diese sachen mache wo ich als erste
person praktisch die bewertung gebe die
fällt jetzt so aus drei sterne essen
fünf sterne lieferungen also in ordnung
halt lassen danach um die hotline